Otto von Bismarck hat es Auswärtige Amt
gegründet führte die fortschrittlichsten
Sozialgesetze der Welt ein gilt aber
auch als Wegbereiter des deutschen
Kolonialismus er galt mich als Demokrat
der frühere Reichskanzler ist aber Teil
der deutschen Geschichte aber nicht mehr
das Auswärtigen Amt ist das
bismarckzimmer wird umbenannt heißt
jetzt sei der deutschen Einheit auch das
Porträt des einzigen Reichskanzlers
wurde abgehängt es ist ja nicht das
erste Mal dass aus der Öffentlichkeit
sagen wir mal Geschichte oder eben auch
Tradition verbannt wird und insofern
geschichtslöschung muss ich sagen ist
ein ganz seltsames Gefühl kommt da auf
weil nur totalitäre Regime haben das
bislang gemacht weltweit dass sie
versucht haben die eigene Geschichte zu
eliminieren und sie neu zu schreiben
diese Tendenz muss eigentlich sofort
gestoppt werden